tell you warren buffett's secret to  finding good managers and partners in  the businesses he owns which is who you  need to look for when you're making a  partnership in your first business  number one is you need to look for  somebody who's got high energy number  two is you need to find somebody who has  integrity and character that you would  be willing and happy to associate  yourself with third they should be sharp  as attack they should know and have  extreme expertise in that space number  four they should have an owner's mindset  about all things related to the business  meaning they're thinking long term not  weekly or monthly or quarterly but what  is going to build enterprise value in  this thing and give us a sustainable  strategic advantage that will be able to  continue for years and years and years  that's how you find a good partner